[Música]
Olá, boa noite todos bem-vindos à nossa
live de hoje. Boa noite,
Blanderson. Conforme vocês forem
entrando, por favor, vão se
identificando paraa gente poder dar o
alô para vocês, tá? Hoje eu tô sem meu
microfone habitual,
então pode ser que o áudio não fique tão
bom, tá? Então, por favor, vocês me dão
um feedback se o áudio está OK.
Vamos começar então respondendo as
perguntas que vocês deixaram. Primeira
pergunta é, deixa eu até colocar aqui na
tela para
vocês. Meu filho tem problema de pressão
alta e está usando sauna na 75º e depois
entrando na banheira cheia de gelo. O
que pode pesar sobre ele em relação à
pressão alta?
Isso é uma pergunta interessante porque
leva a gente a lembrar das técnicas do
Dr. Sinclair para estimular as
cirtuínas, que é justamente o choque
térmico, tá?
Só que a alternância entre sauna quente
e beira de gelo, apesar de ser uma coisa
interessante para causar um estresse
leve no organismo e isso aumentar a
circun relacionada à longevidade. Vou
falar um pouco mais sobre isso daqui a
pouco. Numa pessoa que tem pressão alta
pode ter risco significativo, sim, tá?
Por causa das oscilações bruscas na
pressão arterial. Quando a pessoa entra
na
sauna, existe uma vaso dilatação
periférica, aumento da frequência
cardíaca, a pressão
temporariamente reduz por conta dessa
vaso dilatação e isso persiste por
alguns minutos depois que ela sai da
sauna. E só essa parte da sauna pode
oferecer benefício
cardiovascular se usado de maneira
regular.
Quando a pessoa tá em contato com a água
fria, é o contrário, acontece uma
vasoconstrição e pode aumentar a pressão
arterial em pessoas
hipertensas. Então isso pode ser até nos
casos um aumento perigoso, né? pode até
atingir mais de 180, né, de sórica ou
18, ou mais de 120 ou 12 de diastólica.
Isso pode aumentar o risco de uma crise
hipertensiva e também de uma arritmia,
né? Então, para o hipertenso existe um
risco na alternância entre calor e frio,
né? A transição rápida entre extremos
térmicos pode gerar um estresse
cardiovascular. Isso pode desencadear
arritmia, pode dar crise hipertensiva,
né? Então não é recomendado, a não ser
que seja um hipertenso muito bem
controlado,
tá? Pessoas têm pressão alta, pessoas
têm doença cardíaca ou fator de risco
cardiovascular podem ser
vulneráveis a essa técnica. Mas aí então
voltando ao assunto de por que que as
pessoas fazem isso eh por conta da
ativação das cirtuinas, né, que é a
teoria do Dr. David Sinclair, tá? Então,
os trabalhos desse pesquisador, Dr.
Sinclair, demonstram que choques
térmicos podem ativar mecanismos
epigenéticos ligados à longevidade.
Então, tem essa questão quando você
exposto ao
frio, ativa, né, a cirtuína três que tá
nas mitocôndrias.
Isso aumenta a biogênese mitocondrial,
que é a formação de novas mitocôndrias
via PGC1 alfa e reduz danos
oxidativos. E o calor, por sua vez, vai
ativar a circluína um, que é uma
circulína nuclear e não mitocondrial.
Isso pode melhorar a reparação do DNA e
a eficiência mitocondrial. Então, existe
esses protocolos que o próprio próprio
pesquisador David Sinclair faz, que é a
ciclagem térmica.
é alternância entre
sauna
70ºC e banho de gelo de 4º por 2 a 3
minutos, repetindo dois a três ciclos,
né? Então fica 2 a 3 minutos no calor, 2
a 3 minutos no gelo e vai repetindo
dois, três ciclos.
Existe também exposição isolada, que são
banhos de gelo curtos de 1 a 5 minutos,
ou ainda sauna regular 5 a sete sessões
semanais de 15 a 30 minutos. Então
existe os benefícios documentados desse
choque térmico, aumento da gordura
marrom, melhora da sensibilidade à
insulina em pessoas não hipertensas à
cardioproteção via vaso dilatação e
proteção contra isquimia e longevidade
celular através de reparo de DNA e
autofagia. Então, a alternância entre
extremos térmicos tem-se esses
mecanismos biológicos das
circotínas que são promissores para
longevidade, mas pessoas que são
hipertensas descontroladas tem que ter
muita cautela. Se for impertenso
controlado até vai, se for impertado, eu
não recomendo, tá? que apesar que as
pesquisas indicam que enquanto a sauna
isolada possa ser benéfico para os
hipertensos, a combinação com banho de
gelo pode ter um risco cardiovascular
para pessoas que não t pressão alta bem
regulada, ok? E se a pessoa for fizer
isso, tem que fazer com um
acompanhamento, um monitoramento
médico. Bem, vamos fazer a próxima
pergunta
aqui. Deixa colocar em Bendra que eu
acho que fica mais fácil de
ler. Se germinar sementes de linhaça ou
chia e consumir os brotos, ainda haverá
limitações na absorção do ômega-3,
especialmente idosos. Isso acontece por
algum motivo relacionado ao
ômega-3? Eu não sei se eu entendi
totalmente essa pergunta, né? Mas eu tô
entendendo aqui. Ele tá falando do
ômega-3 na linhaça e na chia, né? Que é
rica em ácido alfa linolênico, que é um
tipo de ômega-3 de origem vegetal. E não
sei se essa limitação que tá sendo
falada aí em relação à conversão do
ácido linolênico, alfa linolênico em DHA
e EPA, né?
pentenico e docosa exenóico, que são as
formas mais ativas do ômega-3 e mais
benéficas paraa função cerebral e do
coração. OK? Então, a conversão do alfa
linolênico, né, que tem
na
linhaça em EPA e DHA, é limitada por uma
enzima que ela não é tão disponível, OK?
A eficiência dessa enzima, ela vai
também diminuir com a idade. Então,
fatores como sexo, genética, presença de
doenças crônicas, consumo de álcool,
ingestão de gordura saturada,
deficiência de micronutrientes, como é o
caso do zinco, do magnésio, da niaacina,
da vitamina C. Tudo isso pode interferir
e reduzir a conversão, tá? Ã, de alfa
linolênico em DH e EPA. OK? Então, mesmo
triturando, germinando, mastigando bem
as sementes, o processo de conversão
metabólica não se altera de forma
significativa. O corpo vai continuar
limitado na transformação de alfal de
linolênico, né, em EPA e DHA.
E para DHA, especialmente pessoas mais
velhas. Então, germinar sementes pode
aumentar a biodisponibilidade de alguns
nutrientes, como minerais e
antioxidantes, e reduzir fatores
antinutricionais. Porém, não tem
evidências de que a germinação aumente
de modo significativo a absorção ou
conversão do alfa linolênico com IEPA
DHA. OK? Então, mais importante para
absorver ômega-3 é triturar e mastigar
muito bem, né, a linhaça, pois a casca
dura impede a digestão e a absorção do
óleo quando ingerido de forma inteira.
Então, para quem busca benefícios
específicos do EPA e do DHA, é mais
interessante você consumir o óleo de
peixe ou o óleo de algas, né, da o óleo
de
cri, que aí você vai ter esses ôegas 3
mais intensos, né, mais ativos na forma
direta, tá? O consumo regular de na Xia,
continua sendo benéfico para saúde de
cardiovascular, por causa das fibras,
dos antioxidantes, etc.
Porém, para efeitos específicos do
ômega-3, é melhor utilizar uma dessas
três opções aí, óleo de peixe, de crio
ou de algas.
Beleza? Vamos pra próxima pergunta
aqui. Através do hemograma, tem como
identificar a verminose e qual exame
para vermes seria confiável?
Tá? Hmograma não é um exame direto, né?
Um exame específico para verminosa. Ele
dá uma pista, mas não é um exame que vai
confirmar. OK? Quais são as alterações
do hemograma que podem sugerir então a
infecção parasitária? A principal delas
é os esoofilia, né, que é o excesso de
inófilo. Só que a esmofilia também pode
acontecer em alergia e também pode
acontecer em infecção por eh fungos. OK?
Que que são osófalos? São células de
defesa que são associados a
infecções e também a
alergias, ok? Então, o aumento
deusinófico pode ser três coisas
diferentes. Pode ser parasita, pode
ser alergia e pode ser fungo, ok? Então,
quando a gente vê a usinofilia no exame
de hemograma, é uma sugestão que pode
ser uma infecção parasitária. Eem alguns
casos também, essa pessoa pode ter
anemia por infecção crônica, por perda
de ferro, pela presença do
parasita e pode ter também aumento de
leucostos ou menos frequentemente baixa
dos leucostó. pode ter
leucocitose ou leucopenia. E pode ter
também linfocitose, que é aumento de
linfócito. Pode ter monocitose, que é
aumento de monócito. Em casos mais
graves, trombocitopenia, que é a redução
das plaquetas. Então, o hemograma pode
sugerir a presença de verminose,
especialmente se houver eusinofilia, mas
não confirma. O ideal então é você fazer
o exame de feses. O problema do exame de
feses que você tem que fazer pelo menos
três amostras, né? O chamado exame
parasitológico de
fezes, que pode identificar ovos, cistos
ou falas adultas de parasita nas
feeses. Eh, e para aumentar a
sensibilidade, pelo menos três amostras
em dias alternados.
Porém, ainda é possível que você faça
três amostras de exame de feeses e não
apresente nenhum parasita, tá? Existe um
tipo de parasita que é o oxiurus, que é
o interóbicos, interóbios
vermiculares, que como ele vive mais na
região anal, ele pode ser identificado
através de um exame de teste de fita
adesiva, né, que é aplicado na região
anal paraa coleta de ovos, né,
especialmente em crianças aí, tá?
Existem também outros exames
alternativos, é o caso da sorologia, que
você pode utilizar para diagnóstico de
algumas parasitoses
sistêmicas ou quando você tem
bastante a suspeita de ter parasita e o
parasitológico veio negativo, então você
pode usar a sorologia para constatar
esquistossomose, toxocares, né, que é
toxocaríase ou assisticercose, né?
Existe também o exame de PCR, né?
polimeraz chain reaction, que é um exame
molecular,
ã, só que é um exame menos disponível,
né, em laboratórios
de referência, eh, ele tem maior custo e
tem uma indicação mais restrita.
Vamos paraa próxima pergunta.
Então, isso aqui é uma pergunta grande.
Acho que vai caber aqui. Vamos ver.
Não, não vai
caber. Bem, vou colocar o que dá para
ler aqui na tela. Depois a gente eu
completo aqui lendo, né?
Eu disse num vídeo sobre vitamina D que
o nível ideal seria entre 60 e 100 e que
a maioria dos médicos consideram valores
menores como sendo ideal. Bem, hoje eu
tô usando o número de entre 50 e 70, tá?
Eu não sei se eu falei num vídeo que eu
não vou lembrar agora que é era entre 60
e 100, mas eu tô usando a referência
entre 50 e 70, tá?
Vamos continuar aqui. Então, fiz um
exame onde os valores de referência do
laboratório eram entre 50 e 200
nanomoles por litro e o meu nível está
336 nanomoles por litro, que é uma outra
unidade. Seria esse valor muito além do
ideal? Teria algum risco de estar alto
assim? Tem um histórico de doença
autoimune, mas parei de tomar a vitamina
D por um tempo para garantir que já que
não estava tomando K2. Vamos lá.
Então, esse número aí que você tá
mantendo equivale a 134 mais ou menos
nanogram por m, tá? Os 336 que você
falou. Isso ultrapassa um valor de
segurança para boa parte das pessoas e
pode não ser arriscado, depende da sua
dieta, tá?
A gente usa, na verdade, vitamina D em
altas doses no protocolo Coimbra para
tratar várias doenças autoimunes, mas
para poder ser seguro isso, precisa
fazer a dieta baixa em cálcio e precisa
fazer reposição de vitamina K2,
magnésio e outros nutrientes,
tá? Então, para pessoas normais, como eu
disse, eu recomendo manter a vitamina D
no sangue entre 50 e 70.
Pessoas que estão fazendo protocolo
Coimbra podem ter valores muito mais
altos do que isso. E aí a gente vai
regular isso através da medida do
paratormônio, do PTH, OK? O risco de
você ter uma vitamina D muito alto no
sangue sem fazer uma dieta
hipocalcêmica, ou seja, com menos
cálcio, é que você pode acumular cálcio
nos tecidos
moles. Isso pode causar hipercalcemia,
que é o excesso de cálcio no no sangue,
que pode levar sintomas como fadiga,
náusea, disfunção do do rim, né,
arritmia cardíaca.
E pode também calcificar o rim causando
nefocalcinose ou calcificar parede das
artérias, tá? Então não faça uso de
vitamina D para ficar acima de 100, né,
nanogram por ml no sangue, a não ser que
esteja fazendo o protocolo Coimbra, OK?
Então, para fazer o protocolo Coimbra
tem que tá tomando magnésio, tem que tá
tomando K2, tem que tá tomando
polivitamínico, tomando muita água e
fazendo a dieta específica de restrição
do
cálcio. Então, você fez bem de
interromper a
suplementação, mantém a sua vitamina D
entre 50 e 70.
Eh, o paratormônio, se você não tiver
doença autoimune, deve estar por volta
de 30. Se você tiver doença autoimune,
aí você pode deixar por volta de 12, se
tiver fazendo o protocolo coimbra,
tá? Bem, vamos pra próxima
pergunta. Eu acho que foi a última
pergunta, né? Deixa eu ver se tem mais
alguma
aqui. Deixa eu ver se tem perguntas ao
vivo. Bem, boa
noite, Eloía,
Eliana,
Denise, Maria
[Música]
Helena. Minha pergunta sobre linhaça
germinada foi mexida. Não
entendi mexida de que jeito?
explica para mim que eu não
entendi. Bem, vamos falar aqui deuns
artigos que eu separei para vocês aqui,
interessantes, né? Tem um artigo muito
interessante sobre o a questão da do uso
celular e a saúde
mental. Será que vocês já pararam para
pensar? Eu acho que sim, né? Quanto
tempo as pessoas em geral, seus filhos,
seus netos, vocês mesmos passam olhando
paraa tela do smartphone todos os dias?
E muita gente já está fazendo uma
associação entre uso de smartphone e
saúde mental. Muita gente acredita que
reduzir o tempo de smartphone poderia
melhorar a saúde mental e o bem-estar.
Então vamos explorar hoje um estudo
fascinante que revelou como uma simples
mudança em nossos hábitos digitais pode
transformar a nossa qualidade de vida. O
estudo é o seguinte.
Foram 267
adultos com idade média de 32
anos e eles concordaram em bloquear
completamente o acesso à
internet nos smartphones por um período
de duas a qu semanas. Então eles
poderiam ainda fazer ligações, mandar
mensagem de texto e até usar a internet
em outros
dispositivos como computadores. Então
ele tava usando SMS, fazendo ligação e
só usava internet em computador. O
objetivo era descobrir como essa mudança
poderia afetar a saúde mental e o
bem-estar, né? Então, os participantes
que bloquearam o acesso à internet nos
smartphones experimentaram mudanças
notáveis. Primeiro, houve uma redução
drástica no tempo de tela, né? Então,
ficaram menos tempo no celular. Estamos
falando aí de aproximadamente 2 horas a
menos por dia. Nossa, 2 horas me a menos
por dia, olhando pro celular é muita
coisa, né?
Mas o mais interessante foi que
aconteceu além da redução do tempo de
tela. Então os participantes elataram
uma melhora significativa do bem-estar
geral. Isso inclui sentir mais emoções
positivas, menos emoções negativas e
maior satisfação com a
vida. Então isso aqui me chamou muita
atenção, pessoal. Eu já sabia que isso
era bem provável de ter acontecido, mas
o estudo realmente bateu muito com as
minhas impressões. E vamos refletir aí,
né? Quantas vezes você se pegou num
ciclo de rolagem infinita nas redes
sociais, especialmente no Instagram,
apenas para perceber que isso não lhe
trouxe nenhuma
satisfação real, né? Além disso, a saúde
mental dos participantes melhorou de
maneira considerável, teve menos
sintomas de depressão, ansiedade, raiva,
ansiedade social e a capacidade de
prestar atenção também melhorou. Os
participantes demonstraram maior
precisão em teste de atenção
sustentada e relataram menos lapso de
atenção no dia a
dia. E quais são as explicações
possíveis então que os pesquisadores
levantaram para essa situação de
benefícios, né, de est com celular
bloqueado paraa internet, né? Então, o
que eles acharam que poderia ser uma das
explicações é o sono. Então, quando eles
bloquearam o acesso à internet no
smartphone, os participantes elataram
dormir mais, né? Sabemos que o sono
inadequado tá
relacionado a problemas de saúde mental,
especialmente a maior risco de
depressão. Os smartphones podem afetar
de forma negativa o sono por vários
motivos. A luz azul é o mais conhecido
que inibe a liberação de melatonina, que
é o m do sono. E além disso, o uso de
smartphone pode nos fazer procrastinar
na hora de dormir, você atrasar a hora
que você vai dormir, fazendo com que
fiquemos acordados muito além do que
deveríamos.
Os participantes também relataram que
usaram o termo, usaram o tempo offline
para atividades como exercícios físicos,
leitura de livros, contato com a
natureza e socialização presencial.
Então, essas atividades poderiam ter
melhorado a saúde mental desses
participantes. E outro fator importante
interessante é o conteúdo que nós
consumimos nas redes sociais. A
exposição frequente a notícias negativas
e publicações pessimistas tem sido
associado a respostas emocionais
negativas como tristeza. Alguns de nós
até desenvolvemos o hábito de rolagem
apocalíptica, né, que é compulsão por
ver conteúdos negativos nas redes
sociais.
E é importante destacar que a maioria
dos participantes,
83% já estava motivada a reduzir o uso
do smartphone mesmo antes do estudo. E
além disso, aqueles que completaram todo
o estudo tinham melhor saúde mental e
capacidade de atenção no início
comparado aos que
desistiram. Interessante isso, né?
Então, no começo do
estudo, né, aqueles que completaram todo
o estudo tinham melhor saúde mental e
capacidade de atenção no início
comparados aos que
desistiram. Então, isso significa que os
benefícios podem ter sido amplificados
por um efeito placebo impulsionado pelas
expectativas positivas dos participantes
em relação à intervenção. Então, nos
parece tentador fazer declarações sobre
os malefícios dos smartphones.
A verdade deve ser mais complexa do que
isso, mas com certeza eu tenho convicção
que as redes sociais está fazendo mal
paraa saúde mental das pessoas, né?
É lógico, os efeitos positivos e
negativos dependem muito de como nós
utilizamos os
dispositivos, porque nós podemos
concluir que para algumas pessoas
limitar o uso smartphone ou das redes
sociais, especialmente próximo à hora de
dormir, é muito útil para melhorar a
saúde mental, tá? E deve ser parte de
uma abordagem abrangente nesse sentido,
né?
E obviamente ser particularmente eficaz
quando esse tempo utilizado de uma
maneira mais saudável paraa atividade
física, para leitura ou para atividades
que promovem maior conexão social,
né? Então faz sentido sim fazer o detox
digital. Os estudos estão comprovando
isso. Pode não ser necessário bloquear
completamente o acesso à internet, mas
se pode criar aí situações de restrição,
estabelecer limites saudáveis que podem
fazer uma grande diferença na qualidade
de vida. Bem, temos um comentário aqui
da Maria Helena.
A pergunta foi elaborada de forma mais
simples e colei ela lá e quando você leu
estava um pouco
diferente. Não, mas eu coloquei
exatamente porque eu não tava. Eu não
mudei a sua pergunta não, né?
Alteração é o que tava lá no na
planilha, tá?
Depois dessas últimas notícias sobre
parto bebês reborn e indo para hospital,
acho que a saúde mental não anda
realmente bem. Eu tô muito intrigado com
essa história desses bebês reborn, tá?
Porque eu tô achando que existe aí algum
tipo
de intenção por trás dessas notícias aí
que estão muito, muito estranhas, né?
Não sei, não me parece uma coisa por
acaso isso não sabe, por mais que as
pessoas que estejam divulgando esses
vídeos de bebê reborn tão querendo
atenção, tão
querendo viralizar, né? E o pessoal hoje
faz qualquer coisa para viralizar, né?
Até antigamente eu falaria que colocaria
uma melancia no pescoço, mas hoje tá
muito além disso, né? A pessoa ela, ela
se ridiculariza nas redes sociais.
para ter engajamento, né? As pessoas
perderam completamente o sentido, o
senso de
autopreservação, contanto que elas
viralizem, qualquer coisa tá valendo,
né? Mas Maria Helena, eu te respondi a
pergunta, não, mas se você
não teve a sua pergunta respondida,
porque ficou um pouco confusa a
pergunta, você pode reformular aqui, tá?
que eu vou tentar te responder.
Beleza? Bem, vamos continuar aqui. Tem
mais um artigo que eu queria discutir
com vocês. É um estudo interessante que
liga a
creatina, a redução do do risco de de
câncer. Boa noite, Alice Vogel, seja
bem-vinda. Ah, obrigado, Mariana. Eu
achei que não tivesse
respondido. Então, vamos falar sobre o
assunto que eu achei bem interessante,
que é a correlação sobre a creatina com
câncer. Nós já sabíamos, né, que a
creatina é muito boa paraa saúde
muscular, para melhorar aí o desempenho
muscular na academia e também sabíamos,
né, que a creatina era muito bom para o
cérebro. Agora, existe aí um dado que
pode ser que a creatina seja
interessante também proteger contra o
câncer. Então, esse estudo envolveu
26.000
pessoas. A idade média das pessoas era
de 50 anos.
Então, os dados foram obtidos da
Pesquisa Nacional de Saúde e Nutrição
dos Estados Unidos. Entre os
participantes, cerca de 10% já tinham
recebido um diagnóstico de
câncer. Mas como é que os pesquisadores
mediram a ingestão de creatina? Então,
eles analisaram a alimentação dos
participantes durante o período de 24
horas. Foram dois períodos de 24 horas
por meio de questionários detalhados.
Como a creatina está presente
principalmente em carnes, peixes e
frutos do mar, eles estimaram, né?
Então, ão uma forma estimativa do
consumo de creatina a partir desses
alimentos. Então, não foi a creatina de
suplemento, tá?
Então, 30 g de carne fornece por volta
de 0,1 g de creatina, então 110 mg
aproximadamente. Então, os peixes
geralmente têm quantidades maiores,
enquanto carnes processadas tem menos
quantidade.
Então, que vamos falar aqui da parte
mais interessante. O que que você acha
que aconteceu com as pessoas que
consumiam mais creatina? Então, os
pesquisadores descobriram que comparado
com as pessoas que consumiam menos
creatina, cerca de 0,03 g por dia,
aquelas que consumiam mais ou cerca de
240 mg por dia tinham 16% menos chance
de ter câncer, né?
Os cientistas foram cuidadosos na
análise estatística, ajustaram as
análises para vários fatores que
poderiam ser confundidores ou
influenciadores, como idade, sexo,
educação, renda, etnia, hipertensão
arterial, consumo de álcool, tabagismo,
diabetes, depressão, exercício físico e
até níveis de chumbo e cadmio no sangue.
Então, dentro de um contexto maior,
analisando os exames, desculpa, os
estudos
anteriores, estudos anteriores disseram
que ou sugeriram que o consumo de carnes
vermelhas e processadas poderiam estar
associad maior risco de câncer. OK?
Então isso que era a ideia mais
prevalente. No entanto, quando
analisamos aves e peixes e quando
ajustamos fatores importantes como
atividade física, tabagismo e consumo de
álcool, geralmente não existe uma
associação entre o consumo desses
alimentos, né, a carnes em geral, a
carne vermelha e mortalidade. É isso que
eu falo já há muito tempo nos vídeos,
tá? o pessoal
eh criminaliza, vamos dizer assim, né, a
carne vermelha, mas eh você tem que
analisar dentro de um contexto de de
estilo de vida,
né? Então, também usando dados da mesma
pesquisa nacional que eu comentei dos
Estados Unidos, mas com participantes de
período diferente, os resultados foram
parecidos. das pessoas que consumiu mais
creatina tinha 18% menos chance de ter
câncer, né? Então é interessante isso
daí,
né? Então tem um detalhe, o estudo
mostrou que a relação entre creatina e
menor risco de câncer era mais forte em
pessoas com mais de 51 anos.
Isso deve ser porque os adultos mais
velhos tendem a consumir menos creatina
e proteína na dieta e tem níveis mais
baixos de atividade física e sofre com
perda muscular.
Então, tem também outros estudos
anteriores que demonstraram que a
suplementação de creatina, aí já o
suplemento, não, a
creatina da comida, né, combinado com
treinamento de resistência ou de força,
aumenta a massa muscular e força em
adultos mais velhos, agora também
potencialmente reduzindo o risco de
câncer, né, apesar de não ser uma
redução muito intensa.
Já os estudos com os animais mostraram
resultados mistos. Então, em ratos,
doses altas de creatina retardou o
crescimento de
tumores. Em camundongos, a creatina
também
desacelerou o crescimento moral,
aparentemente melhorando a função das
células imunológicas anticâncer. No
entanto, houve outros estudos em
camundombos com câncer de mama e câncer
de intestino grosso, né, polo retal, em
que foi constatado que a creatina
aumentou a metástase, tá vendo que tem
dados contraditórios em cobaia,
né? Então o tema ainda é
complexo, a gente precisa de mais
estudos, mais pesquisas em humanos para
ter conclusões mais sólidas.
Aí um detalhe do estudo é que as
quantidades de creatina consumidas eram
relativamente
baixas comparadas as doses usadas em
estudos clínicos, né? O grupo que
consumia mais creatina da alimentação
ingeria apenas 240 mg por dia, enquanto
que a dose de alimentação você sabe que
é de 3 a 5 g diários.
E aí levou a hipótese, será que
realmente é a creatina o fator protetor
ou tem outros nutrientes nas carnes e
peixes que estão protegendo, né? Porque
nós sabemos que tem proteínas, tem
vitamina B12, tem ferro, tem zinco, tem
selênio, ômega-3, né? Quando é carne que
pasta, né? O gado que pasta ou galinha
que cisca, né? E o peixe também, né? No
caso do do ômega-3.
Então, esse estudo mostrou que após
controlar vários fatores de confusão,
consumir mais creatina estava associado
a menores chances de ter câncer,
particularmente pessoas mais velhas, tá?
No entanto, ainda não sabemos exatamente
como é que a creatina poderia reduzir
esse risco de câncer, não se sabe o
mecanismo exato, tá? E essa descoberta
poderia ser explicada por outros
nutrientes presentes nas carnes ou
fatores desconhecidos
ainda. Então, precisamos de um grande
estudo controlado,
randomizado, para entender melhor se a
creatina realmente tem esse fator
protetor. Beleza, pessoal? Temos mais
perguntas ao vivo?
Vou esperar vocês se manifestarem.
Bem, tem mais um artigo que a gente pode
conversar aqui sobre o consumo de café.
Se não tiver mais perguntas pra gente
poder ficar um pouquinho mais tempo
juntos aqui.
Bem, vamos falar desse estudo do café,
então, né? Com certeza vocês já ouviram
fatos negativos sobre o café e fatos
positivos também sobre o
café. Nós sabemos que o
café, sem sombra de dúvida, é uma das
bebidas mais consumidas no
mundo. Esse estudo recente acompanhou
mais de 42.000 1000
pessoas e foi para entender a relação
entre o consumo de café e o risco de
morte. As pessoas que tomavam café
apenas pela manhã apresentaram um risco
menor de morrer por doenças
cardiovasculares. Quem tomava até uma
xícara de café por dia de manhã tinha um
risco 35% menor de morrer por problemas
cardíacos. Com uma a duas xícaras pela
manhã, o risco de morrer por qualquer
causa diminuía 16% e o risco de morte
vascular, cardiovascular, caía a 30%.
Então, o benefício máximo parece ser
atingido entre duas e três xícaras
matinais, com uma redução de 29% no
risco de morte geral e 48% menos chance
de morrer por doença do
coração. E mesmo quem tá tomando eh mais
de três xícaras pela manhã, haveria uma
redução eh desse benefício, mas ainda
mantinha benefícios de 21% menos risco
de morte em geral e
39% menos risco
cardiovascular. E esse benefício não foi
observado em pessoas que tomavam café ao
longo de todo o dia, né? Então engraçado
isso, né? só de manhã que aparentemente
teve esse
benefício. E outra descoberta também que
me chamou atenção é que tanto o
café com cafeína quanto
descafeinado teve benefícios
semelhantes. Então não é a cafeína que
tá causando essas
vantagens. Então esse não é o primeiro
estudo a encontrar benefícios no consumo
de café. Várias pesquisas entre 2012 e
2021 já haviam mostrado que tomar café
estaria associado ao menor risco de
morte em geral, especificamente de
doenças
cardiovasculares. A maioria dessas
pesquisas indica que o consumo ideal
está entre dois e quatro xícaras por
dia. OK?
3,5 xícaras de ásociados ao menor risco
de morte em geral, enquanto 2,5 xícaras
diárias apresentavam menor risco de
problemas
cardíacos. Então, por que que o café da
manhã, né, seria mais benéfico segundo
esse
estudo?
Uma possível explicação que o café
contém eh compostos anti-inflamatórios
como ácido clorogênico, que pode ser
especialmente útil de manhã quando os
níveis de inflamação no corpo tendem a
ser mais
altos. Outra hipótese que tem a ver com
sono, a cafeína consumida mais tarde no
dia poderia prejudicar o descanso
noturno e sabemos que o sono ruim tá
associado a mais estresse fixativo e
mais doenças crônicas, né?
E a maneira como você prepara esse café
também faz diferença. Cafésados sem
filtro, como no método da prensa
francesa, né, ou então a cafeteira
italiana, né, que as pessoas têm em
casa, contém lipídios que podem aumentar
o colesterol LDL e o café filtrado, um
papel geralmente não tem esse efeito.
Então eles nesse estudo tão recomendando
usar mais o café
filtrado. Então mais um estudo aí para
vocês. Ah, tem uma pergunta aqui da
Denise. Ter um bebê reborn realmente
poderia ajudar num caso de perda de de
um filho bebê? Que o que que você acha?
Tem algum benefício? Olha, Denise, eh,
não conheço estudo sobre bebê reborne,
mas obviamente que qualquer tipo
de
eh muleta emocional, né? Uma pessoa que
sofreu aí
uma um impacto, né, um trauma emocional
muito grande, poderia ser benéfico até
certo ponto, né?
Se tem uma pessoa aí que sofreu um
trauma emocional muito grande, perda de
uma criança, poderia usar o bebê reborne
ou um animal estimação, né, cachorrinho
ou um gatinho, como uma maneira
de reduzir o sofrimento, tá? Mas essa
história do do bebê reborne me parece
que tem
outras finalidades por trás dela, viu?
ainda não consigo entender totalmente o
que que eles estão querendo com isso,
mas é uma coisa muito estranha essa essa
onda do BB Reborn agora, né? Mas sem
dúvida, em alguns casos acho que poderia
ajudar, apesar que eu tô falando isso de
opinião, não de conhecimento, de ter
lido alguma coisa a
respeito. Filtro de café para café,
filtro de papel para café irá extrair o
óleo do
café. Pois é, esse estudo que falou
isso, viu, Maria
Helena? Ele tá querendo dizer o quê? que
o óleo do café poderia aumentar o LDL
colesterol e seria maléfico, né? Mas
isso é a opinião do do estudo, não é
minha opinião não,
tá? E eu também acho essa informação um
pouco
estranha. E você, Denise, o que que você
acha sobre essa história desses bebês
reborn aí?
Achando realmente que esse assunto tá
muito estranho. Ja.
Bem, pessoal, vamos encerrar a live hoje
com 45 minutos, tá bom?
Porque
já esgotamos o assunto de hoje
aqui. Esperar vocês se manifestarem
aí. Eloía pergunta: "Então, café de
cafeteira não é recomendado?"
Você tá falando de cafeteira que tem
filtro de papel ou veja bem, eu tô
falando aqui o estudo, tá? Não é o que
eu recomendo
não. Cafeteira, você fala cafeteira que
tem filtro de papel ou você tá falando
da das máquinas que
usam os
sachis? Olha só.
Se o governo deixar eu colocar como
dependente no imposto de renda, arruma
uns 20 bebês
desses. O governo não vai deixar não,
Denise. Nem a pau. Pode
esquecer. Pode
esquecer. Se bem que esses bebês são bem
caros, né? Parece que custa vários
milhares de reais, né? Não viu o valor
exato
não. Obrigada, Maria Helena, pelo desejo
de bom descanso. também desejo ótimo
descanso para vocês aí, tá? Então tá,
pessoal, vamos encerrar aqui a live de
hoje. Muito obrigado pela participação
de vocês e nós nos vemos na semana que
vem. Um grande abraço.